one of the things that human beings
underestimate dramatically is their
capacity to get great at something if
they're totally immersed in it totally
laser focused on something but as i've
coached the very high-end athletes in my
life the top business people and
entertainers i can tell you that most
people underestimate what total
obsessive laser focused really is and
what it looks like because you are way
more powerful than you know you are if
you went crazy psycho obsessed laser
focused on anything even something
you're totally ill prepared for humans
have an unreal capacity to get great at
things even if they don't have a natural
talent for it if they're immersed in it
and to learn something and acquire a ton
of knowledge in a short period of time
as well society is conspiring all the
time in our culture to completely
distract you so you never win to just
divert your focus and attention look
over here look at this shiny thing look
at this tv show look at this sports team
worry about what's going on here in this
war and they get these different things
on television and our phones and in our
lives that just get us distracted so we
never get obsessed we never get laser
focused for an extended period of time
if you are not focused on your goals you
either don't want them or you are afraid
of them you might just not want to do
them you might be in the wrong thing you
might have picked the wrong goals for
the wrong reasons or
you're afraid of your goals you're
afraid of failing you're afraid of it
not working out and what that means
either way the answer is action if you
don't love it move on immediately and if
you're afraid of it move into it
immediately focused action is always the
answer so one of the entrepreneurs that
i've invested into his name is alex he
helps me run toronto dance salsa which
is the largest salsa dance school in
canada maybe north america and we're
sitting down reviewing his goals and
reviewing his habits and making sure
that you know what he said he was going
to do matches to him accomplishing his
goals and there were a couple things
that were big things on the list that he
had to get done and he was afraid of
making a mistake so for example we're
trying to create the interior of the
studio and make a wall that speaks to
the purpose of the company it speaks to
the the mission the vision what we're
trying to accomplish and we want to have
something beautiful that people want to
take their pictures on and he's so
afraid of getting it right he's so
afraid of doing the wrong thing that he
does nothing and every time he opens up
the file to look at what he wants to do
and different ideas he's afraid he's
going to make a mistake he's afraid he's
going to invest time energy dollars
my money into something that then when
people show up saying huh and it doesn't
work out
he's so afraid to fail that he doesn't
take action which becomes the biggest
failure of all so here was our solution
procrastination power hour i said every
day
pph
put it into your calendar for one hour
this is your pph time the thing that you
have been procrastinated on right the
thing that serves the business if if you
procrastinate on it and you don't like
it and doesn't serve the business
great get rid of it that's not we're
talking about it's the things that
you're afraid of the things that you
don't want to make a mistake on that
you're just pushing aside because
there's all this busy work that comes in
because yes we have to respond to
customers and yes we got to do all the
work that goes into the day to day of
running the company
but if you're so focused on just the
day-to-day and never focus on the things
that will actually help you grow the
bigger picture stuff then guess what
happens you never do the bigger picture
stuff especially if it's because you're
afraid then you have to take action so
we plan the daily procrastination power
hour that he puts into his calendar and
he looks at it when he gets there he
thinks what am i procrastinating the
most on and he's got this list and he
starts attacking it and having that in
his calendar is the thing that actually
started building momentum for those big
projects so i've got a three-step
process you can use to stay more focused
and get your work done let's do it step
number one is plan your procrastination
power hour you have to put in your
calendar if it's not on your calendar
it's not gonna get done if you're just
hoping that one day you you magically
get yourself it's not gonna happen the
things that you've been procrastinated
on the things that you're afraid to do
the things that will actually move the
company forward that you've been sitting
on you have to put in your calendar
you've been procrastinating it's not
acceptable anymore it's time to move on
one hour every day dedicated put put it
in procrastination power hour and then
make a list of all the things you've
been procrastinating on and that's the
only thing you're allowed to work on in
that hour don't check facebook don't
check your instagram don't be answering
phone calls no interviews maybe you take
a couple losses for your business that's
okay because you focus on something big
that will catapult the company forward
plan your procrastination power hour
step number two is map your actions to
your ambitions so your actions have to
map to your ambitions what what you say
you want to do what you say you want to
accomplish these goals this vision this
great big thing you have that i know you
have because you're purpose-driven
that's why you're watching this channel
you want to accomplish big things and
have a big impact on the world great
what you say you want are you doing the
steps look at your calendar pull it up
load it up take out your phone pause
this video and load it up and see what
are you doing the next week how are you
going to spend the next seven days look
at the tasks that you've assigned to
yourself the meanings you're going to
have where you're going to be blocking
your time what you're spending that
valuable time you have on do your
actions map to your ambitions if you did
the things that you say are in your
calendar for the next week will that
help you move closer to your goals
success is habits success is what you
consistently do you are what you
consistently do now what happened in
these one-off moments you could watch a
video get all amped up and motivated and
be on fire and work but then you fall
back to regular life that's not going to
move the needle for your business it's
what you do consistently
so every week it's looking at that
calendar and saying if i did this stuff
if i did these tasks if i accomplish
these things i will move closer to
achieving the life that i want and
accomplishing the goals that i've set
for myself your actions have to map to
your ambitions and set number three is
chart your start this is having a
powerful morning routine that sets you
up for success i go through five s's
every morning the most important one is
the third one which is soar where i want
to do the thing every day that makes me
sore that makes me feel like the work i
do matters that the thing that i do has
meaning and value because i can have the
greatest day of all time maybe i'm
meeting an entrepreneur and it's just it
fills me up knowing that i help them but
then i wake up tomorrow and it's like
i'm starting over every day it feels
like i'm starting over and so you need
that injection daily and ideally first
thing in the morning so whatever the
thing is for you whether it's watching
these videos amazing i have one for you
every morning if it's a 254 series that
i have your own confidence or self-love
or motivational speakers all of that
great go sign up it's free you get it to
your inbox at 5am eastern i think every
morning if it's reading a book or
listening to a podcast or doing an
active service and and buy the coffee
for the person behind you in line every
day whatever the thing is that makes you
sore sore like you're bold confident
alive capable of doing great things when
you believe in yourself that you can do
something amazing that's what i'm
talking about making that consistent and
putting into your morning routine
because if you woke up every morning and
did the thing that made you feel
unstoppable bold confident
man i guarantee your life is going to
look dramatically different six months
12 months 18 months down the line you
won't even recognize the person who you
used to be but you have to demand it
from yourself by putting it into your
morning routine chart your start also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there
you get to choose your life you get to
choose how you feel not other people
there's these illusions in life we
really can't control anything other than
our own thoughts our own behavior our
own patterns we can't control what other
people do say or think and it's this
illusion of control oftentimes that we
can somehow manipulate other people or
manipulate situations that cause us to
fall into these patterns but we do have
the power of in life is we have the
power to choose and i say this to you
because i'm somebody just like you
i struggle with the different patterns i
have some of them serve me some of them
don't i sometimes engage in thoughts
that don't create the right emotions for
me that don't serve me i know what it's
like to be frustrated and angry and
depressed and down and lost and fearful
and worried worries a big one for me i
love to fall into the pattern of worry
when certain circumstances begin to
happen it creates a trigger and a
pattern in me and man do i love to worry
and so i give you these tools and
resources because these are things i too
struggle with i've been able to overcome
them by just being aware and choosing
and so the first thing is the power of
choice
finish this sentence for me i choose to
be blissful rather than blank
i choose to be blissful rather than
blank what would your answer be one of
the emotions i challenge you to
experience more of in life is bliss
you know we are the calibration of maybe
the five emotions we experience on a
regular basis
and so if you're experiencing depression
frustration worry fear anxiety pain on a
regular basis you're gonna have one life
if you're experiencing bliss and
fulfillment and ecstasy and joy in your
life and contribution
recognition and significance if you're
experiencing love experience those
emotions you have a totally different
life we have the power to choose which
emotions we want to experience
i'm addicted to one more and so i want
your mantra going forward to be one more
what does that look like if we're
working out that means when we're in the
gym and we say i'm gonna do five sets of
ten i'm crazy like i'm a psycho because
i want to win i want to be somebody i
want to separate
i want to compete
and the way i do that
isn't with my giftedness because i
wasn't born with a bunch of gifts and i
think gifts are crap i think for the
most part gifted people struggle in life
because things come easy them i like
that things haven't come easy for me in
my life i like to have natural talents
in every area and maybe you like that
about you too maybe you've looked at
yourself all your life and thought man i
don't have that natural beauty or that
natural talent or this gift for
creativity or intellect or humor i don't
have any of those things but what i got
is i will outwork you and so at the gym
one of the things i focus on they say
it's five sets of ten when i'm at 10 i
go one more bam 11. if i'm running on
the treadmill and it's a 45 minute run i
never finish at 45. i always go one more
minute 46.
if i'm at the office and i'm supposed to
make 25 phone calls that day when i'm at
the end of the day i always do one more
if i've got meetings i always do one
more my mantra for three decades in
business has been one more there's this
governor on our lives
and it is a governor and it's a it's
your identity it's this internal it's
what you think you're worth
it's what you think you deserve
and the problem for good people see we
all know someone right now in our life
or we have who's not ethical who's not a
good person who's winning and you're
like i can't believe they're getting it
right why can't i i'm a good person i
treat people well i'm honest here's the
reason why by the way the unethical
person eventually karma
you reap what you sow comes home to
roost but if you're a good person this
is so important people understand this
because it took me a long time a good
person in any endeavor will only take
from it what they think they deserve
what they think they're worth in other
words if there was a pizza here you're a
good person you don't take all 12 pieces
a good person thinks there should be an
equitable distribution i'm a little bit
bigger so i might take seven or eight
you know
and i would arm wrestle you for it
i don't know about that you're a moose
but but long story short what is is that
you a good person will not take more
from the table of life than they think
they're worth or they think they deserve
and so you have this governor on your
identity so what happens is our it's
like a thermostat our lives get going we
start doing really well if we're a 75
degree
and our life gets to 85 and 90 degrees
unconsciously we go we don't know we're
doing it
we we start to cool life back down to
get it back to where we're comfortable
the reverse is also true when things
start to go really bad and you're broke
and you're struggling you find a way to
heat your life back up to what you think
you're worth and you deserve so the way
we alter our life is sure we gotta alter
our behavior and our relationships and
our circumstances but the only way it's
permanent
is that we alter that governor that
thermostat and we start to believe we're
worth 85 degrees of life 95 degrees of
life 110 degrees of life and there's
ways we can alter that how do we alter
it a couple different ways a
one is what you just said is that you
put yourself in circumstances
that are demanding of you past what you
think your capacity is and when you
succeed at them you build a new water
line you do you throw yourself out there
past where you're comfortable and you
you do an 85 degrees behavior and you
knock it out of the park you go your
brain starts to believe it repetitiously
when you start doing that you build a
new line now you're 85 degrees that's
number one the second way though is
association
if you're around people and whatever
that endeavor is if it's a sport you're
in or if it's a business or your faith
or your peace if you begin to associate
with people who live in that space at a
higher temperature than you through
association you get heated up yeah and
so if you're an athlete for example
you're a 70 degree athlete and you start
training all the time with 85 and 90
degrees your identity through osmosis
goes up if you're a person is trying to
improve their faith in their life or
their their personal peace about them
you all know this you've seen it when
you start to hang around people that are
a little bit more peaceful than you or
meditate a little bit more through that
association over time the thermostat
changes in that area and so it's both
behaving in certain way and then your
easily changed i believe that let's talk
first of all about getting laser focused
and i mean this is your friend i mean
it's talking to myself too i always
cover things that make me better things
that i struggle with but i gotta tell
you i think there's a different level
for you i mean i think there's a
different level for you to get obsessed
crazy laser focused i say all the time
our obsessions become our possessions
but we won't possess them if we're not
truly obsessed i bet there's been a
person in your life you've been obsessed
with if you're over 20 years old listen
to this more than likely you've had
somebody you were pretty obsessed with
haven't you that you wanted in your life
you wanted to date you want it as a
girlfriend or a boyfriend or a
significant other how many times a day
do you think about them
how many times a day did they distract
you from what you were doing with just
the thought of them
in other words this is what i want you
to understand when you're laser obsessed
focused
your obsession distracts you from what
you're currently doing not the other way
around
you're not really obsessed with it if
you're easily distracted from it
this is so important you right now can
test whether it's your obsession
with whether it distracts you constantly
the first thing you think of when you
wake up last thing before you go to bed
when you have a big laugh it comes up
when you cry it comes up when you're
watching tv it comes up when you're
doing your regular job but it's your
side hustle it comes up you can't stop
thinking about it it distracts you from
the rest of your life
that's what an obsession does when it's
not really your obsession the rest of
your life distracts you from it
and so the it in your life is so
important but there's all these things
that distract us today i'm gonna give
you a recommendation turn your damn tv
off turn the radio off most of the time
turn your phone off a lot too i had a
really good friend of mine i went to
lunch and he said i don't know who this
guy is here
in front of me and he goes let me ask
you a question honestly
right now what are you grateful for and
at the lunch i said
jack
nothing brother there's nothing good in
my life right now
and i'm not exaggerating this to you
when i tell you this and this is a
factual story as i'm mouthing these
words two people walked in with an older
man both of them clearly were fighting
cancer somehow both had lost their hair
one of the ladies had a bonnet on and
they were barely moving in both walked
by our table and gave me the most warm
greeting the warmest smile as a stranger
and he goes that's pretty freaking
pathetic you can't find anything in your
life to be grateful for right now and on
the drive home i'm not kidding you i
started to stack gratitude i started to
take inventory because if you can find
things to be grateful for in that space
man is your life going to be rich when
there really are external things to be
grateful for so my first mechanism out
of that space was honestly to stack the
things i was grateful for and i started
reinforcing it over and over and over
again
and what happens is there's this
reticular activating system in our
brains right and all of a sudden because
that's the messaging i was giving myself
all of a sudden all these things start
to come into my awareness that i'm
grateful for i start to magnetize to
myself some people that i needed to find
into my life and that was the next layer
i started to see things to be grateful
for my health my fitness people who
loved me and what it is it changed my
state when i stacked gratitude i changed
what i did in the morning and i changed
what i did in the evening and so somehow
by grabbing control of my morning and by
grabbing control of my evening i got
some measure of control over the middle
of my day i was an out of control person
back in those days meaning this i woke
up worried stressed fearful and i
immediately start thinking about a bill
i had to pay something that was wrong
and i'm in a state of reaction to begin
every i'm talking within six minutes of
waking up six seconds most people listen
to this that's what they do i said i
gotta grab control of my morning and i
set up routines in my morning
maybe they served me maybe they didn't
but they were things i could deliver on
doing for myself and so not only did
that give me control over the day but i
started to stack my self-confidence too
it's not the success of people you know
that's making you unhappy it's you're
comparing your situation to the success
they're having that creates unhappiness
in your life so for those of you that
are struggling and saying you know one
of the things i suffer from is i'm just
not very happy very often i can tell you
that that presence
of unhappiness you will always link to a
comparison of some sort either in your
own life or in other people's lives and
just being aware of that fact and
stopping the comparison embracing this
moment embracing this time knowing that
you can't go back to that previous time
knowing that you can't be in somebody
else's life you're not gonna have that
other body right now and so if you're
looking to be happier i can promise you
the number one key that i would give you
is to stop the comparison game you'd say
well that's not completely true i mean
what if someone passes away
that makes me unhappy there's no
comparison there let's take the most
extreme example
or when someone's sick in my family
you know someone in my family's got a
really bad illness that makes me unhappy
that's not a comparison in fact it is
the fact of the matter is that when
someone gets sick in your family or
passes away what you do in your mind is
you compare it to when they were healthy
so that comparison of i wish they were
healthier again that is a comparison
between the previous situation and the
current condition if someone passes away
it's comparing the time that you had
them that's why people say if i could
just have one more moment with them if i
could just have another conversation
it's comparing it to when you had the
moment it's comparing it to when you had
the conversation and so those are
extreme examples
but if we reduce it all the way down to
anything right now in your life that you
say it brings me unhappiness there's no
joy there there's a comparison happening
that's not serving you persuasion
anything so if you want to persuade your
children
if you want to persuade someone to take
a look at your faith if you want to
persuade someone in business if you want
to persuade someone to help you in
anything or help them in anything it's
real simple for me monster belief and so
you can't transfer to me that which
you're not experiencing yourself right
so you can't give me that people are
always trying to come with the magic
word the magic clothes the magic this
and there are words you should and
shouldn't use in persuasion no question
about it right there are think there are
words that are more effective than other
words and clearly to be successful in
any business you need to know what those
words are in your business but the best
persuaders the best motivators the best
speakers the best physicians
the best school teachers the best
parents
are incredible persuaders and what they
do is they come from a monster place of
conviction and belief that they can
transfer you to because people respond
to energy
much more than they do words they
respond to what they feel not what they
hear and see hear and see are real low
level influencers energy spirit transfer
of energy is what people respond to and
so i'm cognizant all the time of getting
in a state of total belief and certainty
about what it is that i'm going to
represent or speak of if i'm speaking on
stage about a particular topic and then
transferring that energy into people and
that seems generic or hokey but it's
actually what great persuaders do in
fact if you're listening to this you
think of anybody that you know who's
incredibly persuasive
they may have great words they probably
do but it's something you feel from them
right and that's the difference between
a great doctor and a so-so doctor great
doctor says here's the prescription
you're out of here another one is it's
gonna work or not i don't know another
one you leave their feeling that you're
going to be healed feeling you're in
good hands you feel their certainty you
feel their confidence say when you hear
a speaker if you're buying real estate
from somebody but it's not just buying
things it's a great pastor in a church
a great person if you do tm who's taught
you tm it's their certainty it's the
energy you feel and so for me it's
always getting to i have to really
believe what i'm saying i have to really
feel it to transfer to left to my own
devices
right if you just left me like what i'd
like to do hey man
i have no problem laying around um i
like sleeping i got people think they
meet people like you know they're like
they're robots they're other life forms
they're just different than me no we
build habits rituals and disciplines
that serve us okay now part of those
habits rituals and disciplines have sort
of turned me into a more confident
person there's no question about that so
my standards are mandatory because you
get your standards right so
the reason my standards are set so high
is because i don't want to leave it up
to my own devices right my standard is
one more minute on the treadmill my
standard is one more person i can reach
that day one more phone call one more
something and so for me i raise them
every single year but the way i get to
do it as i link it to my reasons
and so goals are really empty to me i
have a thing on goal setting but like my
big thing is that you show me someone
with compelling emotional gigantic
reasons i'll show you someone who's
changing their standards all day long so
like give you one quick version that
you've not heard before one of the
reasons i'm relatively fit is not just
peak state
i have an uncle in my family that died
at 50 years old of a heart attack my
godfather my dad's only brother i kind
of resembled him
and i look like him a lot so on the way
back from his funeral my reticular
activators on heart attacks
on the tv screen on the airplane i'm
listening to music is the oprah winfrey
show she's going through a new heart
scan
i've unplugged my headphones plugged
into the airplane one there's some of
this new scan at cedar sinai that at
that time was new it could read the
plaques and your arteries the
calcifications without going you know
really invasively i scheduled it i went
in i had a world-class doctor who
understood reasons and leverage instead
of just prescribing when we coach people
you need to do this you need to do this
doctors do it take this pill take this
he understood leverage and reasons
what you do is you take the scan then
you go to lunch you come back i took the
scan i went to i had a burrito
i came back and i'm in the law when i
walk in i sit down the doctor comes up
and he says
oh my
i can't believe these arteries are in
that young body
got my attention we walk back in we sit
down he could still go you need crest
store eat clean get out of here is that
what an average doctor does right no
wired me with huge reasons he goes let
me ask you a question i heard your
wife's pregnant you have i said i have a
son and he says do you want to be there
when he graduates from high school to be
there for that day i said yes sir yeah
he goes your wife's pregnant what do you
have and i said a daughter this is where
you get a dad he goes
she was six months pregnant he goes do
you um would you like to walk her down
the aisle on her wedding day are you
okay that it's some other man
i went what the [ __ ] is on this scan
right like and he goes i want to be very
clear with you if you keep going down
the road you're going there'll be some
other man with your son at graduation
high school and a stranger's walking
your daughter down the aisle that's not
even born yet on her wedding day and i
went boom and he goes but if you do
exactly what i tell you to do
you'll be there and so to this day
brother there are mornings when i wake
up not every morning i don't want to go
to the gym i go bella's wedding bella's
wedding bella's wedding so my standards
are high because of my big old reasons
other dudes may miss the gym that day
because they're not going to miss their
daughter's wedding if they don't go but
i've convinced myself i get emotional
i've convinced myself i'll miss my
daughter's wedding so i will get my ass
out of bed at four o'clock in the
morning and i will get to that gym
because my reasons are bigger so my
standards are higher so that's what i
think
causes us to have great standards is
huge reasons this morning was very
unusual number one was the water was
unusually cold this morning
really cold and the waves were huge very
big waves this morning and both of those
things made me think about business and
there's an application for you that i
wanted to share with you the first one
was just getting into the water this
morning
it was freezing
and when i had to get in there to make a
decision how do i get in do i kind of
take my time or i go my feet in first
kind of get adapt and then come out get
adapted go back in up to my waist get a
little warmer then come back in up to my
neck you get the deal
but all that would do is extend the pain
all that does it's logical makes sense
don't go until you're ready take your
time but really all that does what does
that really do
that extends the pain
and so i didn't do that i did what the
pros do right which is what people do in
every endeavor that are champions is
iran boom right in headlong right into
the water right you dive in there's a
shock
but then you get adapted so much more
quickly than you could possibly imagine
and then you're off to riding the waves
well the same is true in business the
champions and everything i don't care if
it's your fitness if it's your uh your
family your faith you name it the way
that you get great at something is you
dive into it and get adapted quickly and
you'll be surprised at your ability to
adapt and navigate your way through
success the average people in everything
frankly the people who lose are the ones
who constantly take their time they're
too logical they think well i can't do
this until i'm ready if i'm not ready
i'll mess it up and i don't want to get
it's too cold it's too it's too freezing
well the truth is in business that's not
how it works if you go slow you're
extending the time you're in pain and
worse yet
while the champions have already dove in
got acclimated they're out there riding
their waves making progress you're still
on the shore deciding whether you're
going to get ready to get ready
and so if you're an entrepreneur if
you're a business owner you're somebody
getting associated with my firm which is
a wonderful decision by the way but if
you're going to decide that
you've got to decide that and go and
trust the fact that you have your
instincts your background your training
your mentors the system around you and
that's true whether you're an
entrepreneur in my business or you're
one of these firms that i've spoken to
on the outside i want to encourage all
of you if you're going to get in get
into business and go you'll be amazed at
your capacity to evolve and to adapt and
to succeed your mind gravitates towards
which it is most familiar with
and so
if you're really familiar with what
you're worried about and what your
problems are and your fears are and that
becomes your dominating thinking i know
you've all heard this but here's the
reason why your mind loves what's
familiar
okay and so if you don't go touch dreams
for example just experience it for a
second for example we would go down once
every eight weeks if i did well in
business we really knocked it out we
could find a deal i had 200 bucks we'd
go to the ritz carlton or some hotel
ocean and for one day oceanfront feel
like what it felt like to valet your car
right walk in the lobby mr milette
welcome back right she'd go get a
massage i'd play a little bit of golf
and just for that day i'd touch the
dream and then maybe we'd do it again in
a month or two and again in a month just
little taste of it my mind began to
begin to become familiar with it and
more crazy i started to kind of trick
myself into thinking i belonged there
because we never end up anywhere we
don't believe we don't belong and then
we're not familiar with so there's these
things you'd like to do in your life
either visually seeing them over and
over again or repeating those images to
yourself that's powerful but a double
whammy is to not only repeat them and
see them but to go to see
there's one thing that's a visual
stimulus in your brain that makes you
want to do something the triple whammies
if you could see it touch it feel it and
smell it if you allow all your senses to
experience something it becomes far more
familiar to your brain and so i'm a
massive
massive advocate of touching a dream in
any form you can get it the best of
which is actually going and experiencing
it short term
begin to believe you belong there you're
a little bit better and so i you will
not probably produce many things in your
life that you've not visited either
mentally or literally thousands of times
and so if you want to end up somewhere
you better be visiting them those could
be dreams visions but the most important
thing is if you could actually more
powerful if you go touch them short term
massive difference drive by the
neighborhood see the cars if you want to
spend your life in service for your
church or your community take a day out
every month and actually do it know what
it feels like for an afternoon to feed
the homeless or to do and you begin to
love it and feel it and believe you
belong there more and more chance that
you'll be able to do that full-time
someday the key to self-confidence is
really simple
this is absolutely i've trained
hundreds of thousands of people i've
spoken to millions of people around the
world i can tell you this the
self-confident people i know whether
they are athletes school teachers
mechanics
parents stay-at-home moms you name it
they have a pattern of keeping promises
they make to themselves the groundwork
of beginning to build self-confidence is
to begin to keep the promises you make
to you and that's why it's important to
begin to even make small problems if
you're going to get up at a certain time
in the morning not only do it but then
give yourself credit say i did what i
said i was going to do if it's in your
diet or your fitness don't just eat the
healthy foods go i'm doing what i said i
was going to do you begin to build this
reputation if you're constantly being
influenced and moved by what other
people think about you it means there's
a deficiency in what you think about you
and so the key is not some you know enso
esoteric like belief system it's a
pattern of keeping the promises that you
make to you that's the groundwork of
self-confidence
for sure
and it is a pattern when i meet people
that lack confidence i think let me
serve you let's begin to keep the
promises you make to you you're so
worried about there's this addiction to
other people's approval in the world
right it's the greatest the greatest
addiction today it used to be drugs
before there was alcohol there's all
these addictions sex addictions whatever
the number one addiction in the world
today is the addiction to other people's
approval and that's because we don't
approve of ourselves we or we don't feel
a spirit a universe a god that we
believe in that approves of us and so my
confidence comes from both my faith
and in the fact that i keep promises i
make to myself that's the groundwork of
all confidence
i remember going
all the work i put into this all the
hopes my family and i had all the travel
ball all the
everything we did all the games all the
great plays all the errors i made the
fly ball i dropped at fullerton you know
all that stuff i was going to get
drafted then i did all that stuff right
the guys i played with
over
like a flicker man
like a flicker that crap was over and
we're on that bus ride back and i
remember thinking
man i should have tried harder
i should have played harder i should
have given this more
you know the stuff guys do man you're
running sprints there's two dudes who
run every sprint full speed and then
there's a dudes who run eighty percent
six of them you know exactly what i'm
talking about right he's kind of cool
you know it doesn't matter i'm not the
fastest guy so no one will know when i
don't win the sprints
you know those guys you know exactly
what i'm talking about right this guy
kind of doesn't really catch the ball on
his throwing side in the outfield when
his warrior catches it over he does
everything wrong throws it back that's
the thing that costs the guy getting
thrown out at third and you lose by a
run because you just practice like that
the guy in the bullpen is kind of like
not really focused he's just kind of
getting loose right instead of just
laser focused on everything he's doing
all the time
right you don't want to leave here you
don't want it to end whether it ends in
the big leagues it ends in the minor
leagues it ends here or you never even
get on the field this year
okay
having wondered whether you gave it all
you got because it's going to transfer
into the man you become when you leave
here and most importantly it's going to
be your identity when you get tired when
you get fatigued when you get down when
you're in a slump it's your habits
rituals routines and your standards that
carry you through if you don't have good
habits you don't have good rituals you
don't have good routines always in your
life you will fall down in bad times and
slumps and fatigue and stress well i
love that how sometimes the things that
we think are the biggest inconvenience
end up being the best blessings
absolutely man almost every single time
in fact i posted a speech today
that i gave i got invited back to speak
to my college alma mater's baseball team
i played college baseball at university
of pacific and um i went back there and
spoke to the guys and there's a part in
the talk where i tell them that i was so
introverted my senior year i wasn't
going to graduate and i had to take two
electives i was going to graduate and i
got i had previously dropped out of a
sign language class sign language
because i had to get up in front of the
class and sign it was i didn't have to
even speak i just wouldn't walk up there
move my fingers around and i dropped the
class and so it put me where i wasn't
going to graduate
and so the only class i could take to
graduate was drama and public speaking
and i had to take them both and in the
public speaking class i found a
giftedness of mine right and so what
you're saying is completely true i talk
about in this speech typically on the
other side of your greatest fear
of your greatest insecurity
is your greatest blessing everyone goes
well get out of your comfort zone you'll
find this no no where you're afraid of
and what you're insecure about on the
other side of that is typically one of
the great gifts or blessings in your
life and so that's exactly right you and
i are talking right now because i took a
public speaking class my senior year i
was stone ass afraid of in college
that's why you and i are talking right
now so you're absolutely right
and how many people have been touched
now because of you taking that class and
and mutual right and somehow that
blessing that
seemingly inconsequential
scary pain in the ass for me
changed my entire life and has changed
frankly millions of other people's lives
because i went around that thing i was
afraid of it's like you don't even know
the magnitude of what it's costing you
to give into your fears and insecurities
and by the way insecurities and fears
are different things they're both really
insidious detrimental things that people
struggle with and so on the other side
of your fear
that's one thing and on the other side
of your greatest insecurity
are blessings and you have no idea the
immeasurable waves
that you're missing in your life because
you are giving in to them and cowering
to them and so it's like my life's
totally different take me a little
deeper there what's the difference
between fear and insecurity
well fear is something that as you stare
at it
there's a reaction in your body that's
actually healthy it's to protect you we
have fear in our nature because way back
in the day this is how we survive right
so fear is not an unhealthy thing what
it is is it's an alert to you
that hey
there's something here you need to be
more aware of
fear is an awareness emotion what most
people think is it's an avoidance
emotion fear is to make you aware right
so i had a little fear in an odd way
when my daughter was being born when my
son was being warned i wasn't afraid of
having a daughter it was an awareness of
all the great things that could come
with it and my fear of what could go
wrong that day right so thank god my
daughter was born so that fear wasn't
some sign it shouldn't happen or we
shouldn't go through with it it was a
hyper awareness
insecurity is a lie you tell yourself
insecurity is completely different
insecurity is mainly things that don't
exist that you should not be aware of so
ironically people conflate these two
things and insecurity is something that
you've told yourself that is more than
likely a lie about you i'm stupid i'm
short nobody loves me no one's going to
listen to me i'm not strong enough i'm
going to blow this right what are they
going to think about me these are all
fabrications of your imagination fear is
a real thing that you should acknowledge
and see and respond to favorably
insecurities are lies
and so
most people don't make that distinction
and they actually think their
insecurities are things they should be
aware of
when in fact insecurities are things you
should not be aware of totally different
thing the people i know that are really
happy are very self-aware in fact the
best entrepreneurs i know are very
self-aware they're aware of their
shortcomings right they want to improve
them they want to get to the next
version of themselves all the time and
so for me self-confidence comes because
i didn't have it and i think anytime you
meet somebody like yourself or myself
who might now appear self-confident it's
because i really had to find tools and
resources because i was so insecure and
shy and introverted so i had to find
techniques and resources to build that
up in me and for me it's very simple
it's the promises that i keep to myself
if i have a habit over and over
beginning to stack one on top of the
other of keeping promises i make to me
not other people in other words the
minute you begin to get external in your
life worrying about what other people
think about you right you've you've lost
all control you and it never fills you
up and people's admiration people's
gratitude towards you will never fill
you up it's your own it's your own
inside and so for me self-confidence
comes from keeping the promises i make
to myself and the other part of it is
being aware i'm doing it in other words
most people don't give themselves enough
credit all the time they're very aware
of these 20 things and not aware of the
80 right and that's why the dosage is so
important too you've nailed it it should
be 80 20 right because people get
addicted to this i'm not good at this
people don't like this about me i don't
feel good instead of focusing on the 80
and stacking up wow i did eat what i
said i was going to today i did get up
when i said i was going to i made the
amount of phone calls i treated people
in such a way i promised myself it's not
just doing those things it's rewarding
it's being aware of it and stacking that
up you wanted to be a professional
baseball player yeah right yeah but then
you got an injury it did similar to me
so you never made it to the big leagues
or did you play minor league for a
little bit i did yeah and i played
division one college baseball too yeah i
like every guy like you and i talked
about this last time it's always our
injuries that ended our careers i
probably it probably put me
into a premature place where i was going
anyways i don't really realize you
weren't going to be in the bigs for i
wasn't i played enough baseball with
guys who ended up in the big leagues to
know my limitations yeah so like
anything in life things happen for you
not to you that injury happened for me
it certainly didn't seem like it at the
time but it got me out of that and into
something like what we're talking about
now that completely changed my life so
yeah but yeah i want to be an athlete
for sure all my life all your life that
was my mask and then when it exactly and
then when it ended
your identity was like who am i right
yes lost
yeah like a lot we and i were just
telling this before we went on yeah you
know our professional athlete friends
were their career changes
i went into a like anybody like whatever
your dream is when the first one ends it
doesn't happen whether that be a
relationship it could be your marriage
it ends it was a dream right or a
business venture or a sport
i went into a pretty good depression and
how old were you at the time 21 22. and
i ended up you know it's because people
always see the after like the house or
whatever houses or whatever the material
things are
but i ended up bad man i ended up
depressed i ended up moving back at home
with my parents i was living in the city
i remember i was living in this sleeping
of the same bed i grew up in with the
same teddy bear the same posters i was
like going back in time like six years
i'm back where i was totally unemployed
and uh couldn't find work didn't have
the motivation to get up and find a job
just sort of eating out of their fridge
and laying around all day so that's
where i was many many years ago after
base poland when you realize things in
your life happen for you truly
especially in hindsight everybody knows
it in hindsight right if you look back
at any disaster tragedy most people look
back five ten years ago that happened
for me that was actually a good thing
and so i was unemployed i couldn't find
a job
and my old man my dad was the best dad
role model you could ever have in your
life
hard-working man good man it's better
man than me has more integrity than me
he's the best man i've ever known but
when i was growing up my dad had a
drinking problem and so my dad had
gotten sober recently and he was going
to these meetings and he comes home from
one of his meetings and says there's a
guy at my meeting who can get you a job
it's right down the street in san dimas
you're going to be working with kids
doesn't pay anything at six bucks an
hour but you're gonna get this damn job
so show up there tomorrow morning 8 a.m
ask for tim
so i walked
i drive down there it's a place called
mckinley home for boys little did i know
that would alter
my entire life that was the most
significant thing that happened to me
and so i walk in there
i said i'm at my let i'm here for the
job they're like what job i'm like i
don't know just my dad told me to show
up here yeah
i need to ask for tim they're like
we have no idea who the hell tim is
what's his last name i said i i don't i
don't know his last name and they're
like so you showed up for a job that you
don't know what it is and you don't know
who it is it's hiring you i'm like
here's what i know he's an alcoholic
like oh
yeah we know that too
and so they bring me to the guy and he
says uh you're hired let's go like
literally shakes my hand and you're
hired and he introduces me to these
eight boys that were my boys they were
seven eight and nine years old and
basically i lived with these boys these
precious boys and we ended up adding a
few more my boys were all wards of the
court they were all molested by family
or parents were in prison
and so they had no family and so my
whole life changed all of a sudden these
became i'm this 22 year old guy these
guys become my sons wow and i did
holidays with them i did birthdays with
them i i lived with them literally in a
home or like a little morning mckinley
is a massive campus full of children
that have been displaced from their
homes that live in individual like
cottages like a foster care facility
massive though really yep all boys
it's in san dimas here and um wow it
just altered my life man because i had
been an athlete had a huge ego had that
mask i wanted to compete i wanted to win
i wanted attention i wanted recognition
first time literally in my life i went
wow i i love helping people i love
making a difference and my boys were
just come from horrendous situations and
so just i always say this all the time
and i have those eyes too you have them
i think sometimes kids who grow up when
some dysfunction they just have
different eyes yeah they just have these
eyes that are these boys all were
different but they had that same eyes
they're just like
man love me believe in yeah you know
care about me and i had those eyes
because i grew up in an alcoholic family
and my whole life changed i just went
wow i love
i actually love helping people and being
involved in people's lives i didn't know
that because everything was you're great
you're great you know what it is when
you're an athlete right everything's
about you you're amazing free dinners
free this you're a stud
all of a sudden i was in a stud and all
of a sudden it wasn't about me it was
about these ten boys that ended up being
ten of them and it just altered my life
man and so after that i ran into the
financial business that i ended up in
but i would have completely flunked out
of that financial business had i not
been with my boys for those years and i
was there for two years two years yeah
man like eight hours a day type of thing
or sometimes more sometimes 16 18. i i
think about i'm not kidding you i think
about my boys and my experience there
two of them are still very close with me
uh every day there's a moment where i
reflect on that it altered me completely
like what i wanted to do and i always
wanted to be famous and rich and
successful and now i just wanted to
serve yeah i wanted to help little did i
find out i could get rich and famous and
all that other stuff i thought i wanted
through serving people identity is the
governor on our lives it's the invisible
force that no one understands and once
they do understand and get a hold of it
their life can change and so not only if
you don't get a hold of this well these
outward conditions of your life keep
being exactly the same but it's you
could behave differently you could do
all the work out you could be thinking
great thoughts but you are going to get
out of your life
you're going to be the most powerful
force in the world i think is to be
consistent with the concepts ideas and
worth that you hold for yourself you
will get that out of your life what you
will tolerate okay the deeper part of
that is identity and so identity is very
much like a thermostat sitting on a wall
right this is important once that
temperature is set at a certain degree
everything in the world externally can
hit it and you will find a way to get
that temperature so even in this house
let's say it's set at 80 degrees if we
opened up all the doors in cold air just
the worst things in life the blizzard of
life came in the thermostat will kick
the heater on and it will regulate this
room back to 80 degrees the reverse is
also true it's a super hot day great
things are happening in your life it's
getting hotter and hotter and hotter if
you're at 80 degrees that internal
thermostat will find a way over a window
of time to cool your life right back
down to 80 degrees again so the key the
secret key is to be able to shift that
identity 90 100 120. so some of the ways
strategies to do that are are very
simple one is if i let's just say
financially
you're a 200 degree and i'm an 80 degree
if i'm in your proximity over and over
and over and over again you will heat my
identity up somewhere in between mine
and yours to 150 degrees same in fitness
same in everything so the more you can
layer in multiple people the stronger
and stronger that force is so that
changes our thermostat through
association it's a huge huge huge huge
thing people say you are who the five
people you hang around this is why they
adjust your thermostat that's number one
second way you can change your identity
is through doing short bursts of
something in a window of time you've not
done them before and they change the
thermostat temperature permanently
almost like a water line in the pool so
if it's a certain in the gym certain
amount in the gym or a certain amount of
phone calls in your business or certain
amount of appointments you make a
certain amount of money oftentimes
you're never the same again you've seen
this when your own net worth i've seen
it in mind there became a point where i
made a leap and a short window i was
never really the same again i could go
back a little bit but not back where i
was before so it's activity or successes
achievements in short bursts of time and
then our obviously our self-confidence
impacts identity too and we've kind of
covered that those are three quick ways
that's incredible so walk me through
your
your baseball career ends
um i know that your dad and you are now
you said he's your best friend was my
best friend growing up
alcoholic father correct you said until
i think you were 14 or 15. that's right
and then um they're introducing you
constantly as the shy kid who plays
baseball baseball falls away and now
it's like
how do you get out from under well i'm
the son of uh you know somebody that
struggled with drugs and alcohol i'm
the kid who was supposed to be great at
baseball and now that's gone like how do
you get out from under the weight of
that yeah it is weight too um when i was
small mom i was also really undersized
so it's probably one of the reasons i
lift weights i was always every baseball
picture on the kid holding the sign in
the front right so i was small and
skinny they used to tease me eddie
spaghetti you know and i'd get bullied
at school and i never retaliated so i
had that mixed with shyness mixed with
chaos in my home which many people can
relate to and i got to tell you that the
shift for me sports was good for me
because it gave me an out that i finally
found something that i was pretty good
at
i think the biggest shift in our lives
the things that makes us the happiest is
that when somebody helps us identify our
natural giftedness
and when i was a little boy when i got a
little bit older they pointed out my
speed
so it wasn't my lack of size i was fast
i was the best kid right i always wanted
to be fast kid and i got confidence in
baseball doing that when i got into
business they said you know you're
intense when someone points out a gift
about you that you also kind of
intuitively know to be true
they're linked to them you're intense
you're passionate you won't get out work
you're relentless i want i am those
things and when someone linked those
gifts to me winning now i believed i
could win that's the other way to change
identity is when someone can link your
giftedness to the victory you'll believe
it not like you're great that's general
that's [ __ ] but it's something you
know specific like for you right now
you wouldn't brag about there's a few
things you know you know what i am good
at these things right i've always been
good at these things it's natural for me
and when someone links that to you
winning like for you for example you're
an unbelievable interviewer you have
this general
you you don't need to be the smartest
person in the room because you probably
are most of the time and so there's a
confidence no there's a confidence that
allows you to be present when you
interview me and just listen that's
different than anyone who's interviewed
me before and so that's a natural
giftedness for you which is why there's
a part of you that kind of knows i am
pretty you wouldn't say it but i am
pretty good at this this is a good
program and so the way we change our
identity the way i changed mine was by
getting in touch with what some of my
natural gifts were and then using them
in my career using them in my life that
shifted the weight right off of me
because the weight was i suck i'm shy
i'm small i have a screwed up family
that's the weight right the lifting off
of the weight is these are some gifts
god gave me or the universe gave me or
that at least i know i have and i can
spend my life using these gifts now i've
got hope now my identity is changing now
my life takes a different direction one
thing i want to challenge you to be as a
leader of your business whether it's
just you're a leader of one which is you
as a salesperson or a leader of 10 as a
team or a company of 25 000 employees is
you must become evangelical about your
cause and your mission the greatest
business people have an evangelical
property about them they're evangelizing
all the time they're propagating the
strengths the benefits of their business
of their mission of their cause one of
the great evangelists of all time is
steve jobs is a great book written by a
guy named guy kawasaki many years ago
called selling the dream
and in that book he talks about the way
that steve jobs sold the dream of apple
and he literally called him an
evangelist for the cause there's a great
story in that book about steve jobs when
he was recruiting he knew he needed to
have a ceo of his company and he wanted
to have the best and at that time there
was a man named scully who was the head
of pepsi and jobs was this young kid in
his 20s trying to recruit this executive
had made millions of dollars and he
couldn't get him and he couldn't get him
and he couldn't get him and finally he
gets the voicemail back in those days
the answering machine actually of scully
and he says listen
listen man when you're tired of selling
sugar water to kids over there at pepsi
and you want to come change the world
freaking call me back and we'll do it
together boom and he hangs up right he
was evangelical the cause
sugar water and pepsi changed the world
at apple right and scully who's making
millions of dollars a ceo of one of the
most powerful companies in the world
looks to his wife and she says
i think he's right we aren't changing
the world and it was that one
cause-oriented evangelical phone call
from steve jobs and it exuded out of his
pores every stage speech he gave every
one-on-one every board meeting when he'd
meet with their software engineers when
he'd meet with the programmers he was
always evangelical internally and
externally and built a culture of one of
the greatest movements of all time in
the history of business let me tell you
one thing i've noticed about all the max
out performers that i've interviewed on
my program that i've known throughout my
life for the last 30 years really in
business sports entertainment politics
you name it the elite performers look at
time and use time completely differently
than the people who perform at an
average level the first thing i want to
tell you about people who win who max
out they are in a much bigger hurry than
the people who are average and i'm not
kidding you when i say this they're in a
bigger hurry to get to their destination
to get to their outcome their pace is
faster they walk faster they talk faster
and their expectation when they're going
to arrive at their destination is sooner
this may seem like a very small subtle
thing but i want you to evaluate how big
of a hurry are you in
because there's something to be said
about how close you think you are to a
goal
and how fast you will run to get to the
finish line let me give an example of
that if you and i started out right now
and we had a 26 mile marathon to run
right in our minds it was 26 miles we
were going to race each other
we would pace ourselves at a certain
speed in order to maintain that speed
because of the duration of the run so it
was a marathon we'd jog wouldn't we
pretty slowly you certainly wouldn't
sprint 26 miles and so because the
destination because the finish line is
so far away
our pace or our hurry is limited based
on how far away we think we are or when
we'll arrive there but if you and i were
to run a 100 yard dash
would the pace be the same because the
finish line is so much closer we'd run
full speed from the minute we took off
wouldn't we because of the proximity of
how close the finish line is
the people that win in life don't
necessarily have more vision than you
see it's not a lack of vision always
that means that you're going to lose
it's a lack of a type of vision which is
depth perception you think you're
further away from the outcome and so you
pace yourself like it and you jog all
the time throughout your life the people
that win may have a bigger vision but
they have accurate
depth perception they understand how
close their goals are how close their
outcome is and they're constantly in a
sprint to get there throughout their day
that means consequently they get started
earlier and they finish later they get
up earlier throughout the day they're in
a bigger hurry to get to the places they
need to be because the finish line in
their mind is so much closer
i cannot emphasize this enough to you is
just the pace and the way time shrinks
for elite performers compared to the
average i'm telling you the average
performer can say the same things read
the same books have the same schedule
yet the person who is in a bigger hurry
throughout the day ends up winning the
day winning the week winning the month
winning the year and winning the life
i've been getting asked lately about the
struggles people are going through with
self-doubt not believing in themselves
negative thoughts about themselves and i
believe the solution to self-doubt is to
build something bigger than that doubt
which is to build our self-confidence
and one thing to know about the fact
that you doubt yourself is one i
struggle with it as well one of the
reasons i've had to go learn to build
all these tools for myself is because in
my life my baseball career my academic
career my business career my speaking
career
i've been riddled with self-doubt that
creeps up all the time in our lives am i
enough am i good enough you weren't born
doubting you weren't born discouraged
you weren't born thinking negative
things about yourself those were
thoughts that were placed in you
and given to you by an external source
at some time in your life it could even
be our parents
don't do that be quiet sit down be a
good boy be a good girl maybe it was
criticism you received as a as a little
one that you may not even remember to
this day the process of building
self-confidence is actually very easy
believe it or not self-confidence is
self-trust self-confidence is building a
reputation with yourself that you keep
your word to you that you keep the
promises you make to you when i meet
somebody who has a ton of
self-confidence i don't look at that as
somebody with a big ego there's a
difference somebody with self-confidence
has a reputation with themselves that i
do the things i say i'm going to do
that's where self-confidence comes from
when i meet someone who's not
self-confident i know this is someone
who has consistently made promises to
themselves they've not kept they've
started a diet and done it for a while
but not kept it they've made a
commitment and goals to go make a
certain amount of money in business and
they started down the road but then they
didn't deliver on it long term to get up
at a certain time in the morning and
then they don't do it and so they have a
process and a habit in their life more
often than not of not keeping the
promises they don't make to other people
they don't keep the promises they make
to themselves and so the cool thing is
self-confidence is an internal game you
do not need external accolades external
admiration in order to build
self-confidence you don't need any of
those external forces it's all done
internally you control this and you
control this by beginning today to keep
the promises you make to yourself and
you have to stack the deck in your favor
stack the game so you win it's not good
enough just to keep the promises you
make to yourself you must acknowledge it
when you do it to you to give yourself
credit to create confidence momentum is
what i call it so whether that's setting
the deck where you're going to get up a
little bit earlier you're going to make
a certain amount of phone calls you
misses a certain amount of appointments
you're going to need a certain amount of
calories in your fitness you're going to
spend a certain amount of time with your
children or your parents and you begin
to do these things you say you're going
to do you say simple things like i'm
going to lay out my clothes the night
before i go to bed every night
before i go to sleep so when i wake up
that decision is made for me and believe
it or not the fact that you just do
something that simple that you then
deliver on begins to build confidence
you say i'm going to stretch in the
morning when i get up and you do it all
of a sudden i'm not going to check my
phone for 30 minutes all these habits i
teach when you just begin to do the
things you tell yourself you're going to
do
you begin to build self-confidence which
is this reputation with yourself so ask
yourself a question right now
what is one thing right now one promise
i can make to myself that i'm going to
begin to keep starting this minute
and begin to do it it could be how often
i'm going to pick up a book and read it
but you begin to stack things you commit
to do and then you deliver on them and
you acknowledge them to yourself you're
in the process of building
self-confidence why is that so important
of all the athletes i coach when my
athletes are performing at their peak
level they're at their highest
self-confidence level in fact i love
when i watch some of the athletes i
coach get interviewed and they kind of
do this aw shucks humble routine
in their post game interviews yeah you
know just part of the team you know i
got a lot i could have done a lot better
today but inside i know these people are
incredibly self-confident people any of
you athletes listening to this you know
this the great athletes you know have
incredible amounts of self-confidence
you have to believe in you when it's a
battle when you're a hitter against a
pitcher or when you're a quarterback
against a defense or you're a defenseman
the nhl against their best offensive
player or you're a golfer and you have
to make a nine foot putt to win a
tournament right you better have
self-confidence in fact the separator
more often than not at the highest level
in sports is not they're a better
shooter or a better putter or throw the
ball a little bit faster because
everybody throws hard in the major
leagues nowadays it seems right
that separates their self-confidence
it's true in being a parent it's true in
being a business person it's true in
every area of our life the separator at
the top levels is self-confidence you
are one decision away from changing your
life
and you have to accept that your one new
meeting one new relationship one new
contact one new action
one new decision
away from shifting your life from where
it is right now to a totally different
place so what's the decision you already
know i could go backstage now there's
something you've been hesitating on
there's a contact you need to make isn't
there there's a job you need to quit
there's a relationship you need to
engage in maybe there's a relationship
you need to leave
i don't know what it is but i know
there's a decision that you need to make
to take you to the next level just like
i know that's true for me because
decisions shape our destiny when they're
backed up by some massive ass action
okay but you can't take the action if
you don't decide everyone say yes people
avoid being desperate think of the fact
they come here tonight and they're down
they're not where they want to be
financially their relationships aren't
what they want maybe they're in a
desperate place and you might think
that's a negative thing but when you're
in a desperate place you take the best
actions desperation is a great place to
be those you that are achieving one of
the reasons the achievement has slowed
down is you've allowed yourself to feel
less desperate
when you are broke and starting your
business or when you were brand new in
your relationship and you were desperate
to get her to love you or desperate to
get him to love you you took massive big
action how many of you are moms in the
room raise your hand you moms if you
woke up tomorrow morning and your baby
wasn't in their bed
would you be desperate right away yes or
no
big time desperation you wouldn't be
thinking about what you need to do you'd
be acting wouldn't you you'd immediately
make the decision you take massive
action you searched the house you'd go
into the street would you worry if your
makeup was on right how you looked what
people thought about you
you wouldn't would you have to have the
perfect plan to go find your baby that's
missing you wouldn't need any of that
because you were desperate
so when you remove desperation all this
[ __ ] creeps into your life where you
think you have to have the perfect plan
and look the perfect way and have the
perfect thoughts and be all zen and
perfect what you need is to be desperate
what you need is to get after it and i
want you to get desperate to make that
decision
why because our obsessions become our
possessions which you obsess about most
regularly you will eventually possess in
your life the challenge for most people
sisters and brothers is that we obsess
on the things we're fearful of what we
don't have what we're worried about and
then we end up possessing those things
over and over again rather than
programming ourselves to become obsessed
with what we want what our dreams are
what we believe we deserve when we
become obsessed about those things long
term we end up possessing those things
can i get an amen for that yes
yeah most of us don't replace the
external parts of our lives because
those things happen
naturally without thought the external
results of our life in order to replace
ourselves with the next best version
requires intention requires obsession
requires desperation everyone with me on
that say yes
so it's not unnatural to change
your friends that think you're crazy to
have started your business or come to a
seminar spend money you don't have
they're the crazy ones
it's unnatural to be the same person you
are right now next year for all of you
in here the 35 year old you should be
gone next year forever and there should
be a brand new better 36 year old you 20
year olds there should be a better 21
year old next year you should constantly
be replacing yourself just like your
bones do just like your lungs do just
like your cells do it's natural to be
replacing ourselves but we're around
people who aren't so we think it's
natural not to couple ironic things
about closing and selling that you may
not have ever been told before but i'm
going to tell you
people don't have to believe what you're
saying
is that crazy
people do not have to believe what
you're saying in fact too many of you
spend too much time trying to get people
to believe what you're saying
and you come across like a beggar
because of it
you seem desperate who's ever trained
you to get people to believe what you're
saying
doesn't get influence
there's a subtle difference that the
great ones know
and you've probably never been told this
before but i know it
and persuasion is not about getting
people to believe what you're saying you
ready
persuasion is about getting people to
believe
you believe what you're saying
that's a subtle difference brother
that's a subtle difference sister if you
start to think through i need to get
people to believe i believe this not to
get them to believe it people buy things
all the time they don't believe
people buy things all the time they
don't understand that's okay we want to
educate we want to train but they don't
have to believe everything you're saying
if they have to do that you're going to
look like you're begging all the time
they got to believe you believe it
that's a different intention the most
certain person always influences the
less certain person when you're
exchanging with a recruiter a client
they're either going to close you or
you're going to close them
and that's certainty certainty is
influence and you can't transfer to me
something that you're not experiencing
for real you have to really believe it
you got to really be a crusader you got
to really understand it when you really
believe something you can transfer that
certainty to me everybody with me on
that say yes this is a huge deal it's a
huge deal that you need to begin to
understand
that persuasion is they believe you
believe what you're saying i love that
most people don't take anything
seriously i love that most people aren't
coachable i love that most people don't
do what i teach or that anybody teaches
i love that that's how certain people
win half y'all haven't written a damn
word down i've said if you were in my
team i'd slap the hell out of you
i don't say that disrespectfully i say
this as a dip who had a velcro car
i don't say that talking down to you i
say wake up
you want to win you want to be a
millionaire you got to quit being so
casual
you walk slow you talk slow you
implement things slow you talk a good
game like you're going to be somebody
like you're gonna make hundreds of
thousands of dollars you can't even
write a note down
you're gonna get your ass kicked in
business dude
business is a sport it's competitive you
gotta get focused
and get in a hurry
around a dude like me we will smash your
organization we come to play we're for
real
what are you
cool
i've seen all kinds of cool guys my
whole career
cool guys go broke
cool guys have little flashes in the pan
they have a good two or three years
players who implement strategies that
get focused and intense they win decades
they win multiple championships you win
for two or three years you know many
guys i've known that have made money for
two three four years that are ass broke
now
you gotta win year after year after year
to be a player in business and if you
want more fire and espresso videos check
out the one that we recently did the
link is right there next to me i think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
i'll see you there